here we have this very capitalist
culture and country and we have this
incredibly socialist transportation
system where the idea of having the
private sector build and run a road is
just crazy talk and over in China where
it's an validly communist system the
idea of having the private sector build
and run a road is like well yeah how
else are we going to build all the roads
[Music]
I'm Hadrian more I'm vice president at
Reason Foundation I'm a transportation
economist and I do a lot of work on
urban transportation systems and and how
to pay for transportation how to make
markets work in transportation I've been
working now for a number of years on a
project in China working with some
universities in China as well as one
municipal government there on figuring
out some ways they can approach their
transportation systems that take
advantage of pricing and markets but
also builds out the kind of
infrastructure they need for the
population growth they have they've got
a fair number of cities that are you
know bigger than any city in the u.s.
except for New York and you've got
cities there where they're growing by a
hundred thousand people a month and
they're going by ten thousand cars a
month just think about building that
many parking spaces to you know to have
to accommodate cars coming into a city
at you know 100 120 thousand 30,000 a
year the cars you know transformative in
China because it's such a new phenomena
it's only in the last you know decade
that the number of cars in these cities
has really taken off and that small
business people can pull up enough money
to buy one the Chinese have put a lot of
emphasis on building a lot of
infrastructure and in some ways that's
been beneficial to them because its
growth it's driven largely by their
human capital it's their people moving
to the cities being entrepreneurial in
recent decades getting the freedom to
pursue their entrepreneurial drives or
to go to school as they've ramped up
their higher education system so these
the human capital is just exploded in
China and that's what's driven their
growth recognizing that you need a lot
of transportation to move the goods and
services around for that kind of growth
they've built a lot of infrastructure so
you know if the government is going to
be responsible for infrastructure you
wouldn't want a short shrift that and
hold back your economic
grow the bad side is of course that this
is a highly authoritarian government
highly authoritarian society they've not
held back from displacing millions of
people in order to build this
infrastructure there's no property
rights there so they've done what they
want when they want and how they want
which when it works you know looks like
an economic benefit because you're not
counting the cost all the people who are
displaced or pushed aside and when it
doesn't work or when you have problems
of corruption which still you know crop
up not infrequently in China there's a
lot of resources they get siphoned off
or wasted I don't actually find rush
hour in Chinese cities to be that
radically different from rush hour in
Chicago or Los Angeles you know they're
wide freeways in there you know
wall-to-wall cars going you know half a
car length at a time very you know what
I experienced on the 405 in LA is a lot
of what I expect on the third Ring Road
in Beijing whenever I go there so stop
and go congestion is the same no matter
what the scenery is like in a sense in
China the the big difference is you see
a lot of other people traveling by means
other than cars still what you don't see
in the US I mean in the u.s. outside of
New York in cities like Chicago in San
Francisco you still got more than 80% of
the people traveling by car so yeah you
might see the train go by in Chicago or
San Francisco or the BART line or
whatever but you don't see people a lot
of people walking you don't see a lot of
people biking there is every city in
China that you travel through by car
when you're stuck in traffic you see
that there's a lot of people walking
there's a lot of people biking there's a
lot of people on those buses and trains
they're full they're not like the empty
buses and trains
you see in most US cities so that's the
real difference is there
they really do use all the modes of
transportation much more so than we do
in the u.s. because in the u.s. we're
wealthier and everybody has cars you
know that I've always been fascinated by
the fact that if you're a poor person in
a city in the United States and you do
not own a car you borrow more rides from
friends with cars then you ride the
transit system according
to National Statistics so you know it's
an interesting system where bumming a
ride is a more better system for most
people than using the public transit
system in China it's nothing like that
it's a much more so many people don't
own cars cars are so new there they
travel by other means and they just take
it as a matter of course transportation
planners in the US you know think we a
lot more of us should be walking and
biking and so forth is there always
making this argument that we should get
out of our cars and I say you know
everywhere I go in the world where
that's actually occurring all those
people are trying to get into cars and
that's not just China that's Europe
that's Asia that's everywhere now is the
Chinese cities are getting congested as
the number of cars in these cities is
exceeding the capacity of the road
system that they built even with all the
new roads they have built in all the new
roads they are building the government's
wrestling with how do we deal with this
congestion and they're not willing to
trade off their growth in that industry
in order to reduce congestion so
experimenting with congestion pricing
they're looking at how do they build
better systems to manage their
transportation networks using a lot of
new technology adopting new technologies
much faster than we do in the US and you
know they're more willing to keep
building as they grow you know in the
u.s. we've almost stopped building urban
transportation infrastructure or at
least automobile infrastructure even
though the number of automobiles and the
distance people are driving and the
number of people driving them keep going
up so we're cramming more and more into
the same size bag they're cramming more
and more to the same size bag but
they're recognizing they got to get a
bigger bag as they're building out their
interstate highway system which they're
in the early stages of building that
national interstate highway network they
are planning to make an awful lot of it
toll roads because that's the only way
they can combine I mean they need that
sort of revenue to build the things in
the first place and in the second place
if they don't have tolls on them they'll
just get congested so they they want to
use pricing you know scientifically in a
sense to figure out you know if the
price gets too high we have to build
more Road in the u.s. we much more have
the attitude at least at the local level
transportations a problem and if people
moved less we'd have less of a problem
and so we're not trying to figure out
how do we make our transportation system
better in our cities so we can be more
economically competitive and China
they're constantly thinking about how do
we make the transportation system in our
town work better so we can be more
economically competitive the idea that
infrastructure is important to our
economy and that infrastructure
investments can have a positive effect
on getting out of recession makes sense
the question is where does that come
from and what drives it having the
central government try to pump more you
know money distributed through political
systems is not the right way to do it if
we you know borrow a lot of money from
the future to pay for building a lot of
infrastructure now that will help us get
out of the recession which i think is
the wrong headed way stimulus hasn't
worked it doesn't work
borrowing just means that when we do get
out of the recession there'll be less
money then to spend then because we've
already borrowed it all so it just it
flattens out our climb out of the
recession for the foreseeable future
it's a terrible way to approach things
having local projects that can be done
you know executed by folks who are
willing to pay for it and most
importantly I think recognizing there's
a lot of private money willing to invest
in roads where people are willing to pay
to use those roads and I should say
somewhat the same at a lesser extent for
transit systems if there's there are bus
lines and projects out there on public
transit where enough people are willing
to pay for it where you might be able to
get private capital to invest to build
that thing but it's overwhelmingly true
for a whole number of projects on the
road side and we're still stuck in this
sort of you know we're here we have this
very capitalist culture and country and
we have this incredibly socialist
transportation system where the idea of
having the private sector build and run
a road is just crazy talk and over in
China where it's an a valid Lee
communist system the idea of having the
private sector build and run a road is
like well yeah how else are we going to
build all the roads yeah so how crazy is
it that we're that backwards in the u.s.
that we can
we can just barely wrap our brains
around the concept of the private sector
building a doggone road so we've got to
overcome that we've got to embrace that
to build the transportation system we
need to get everybody where they want to
go especially think 20 years we better
have a lot more transportation by then
or we're all just going to be staying
home
[Music]